hay una hamburguesa frente a ti pero tú
no la quieres
quizá porque eres vegetariano oa lo
mejor porque ya estás satisfecho y no
quieres comer más o quizá no estás te a
otra persona a quien le gustaría
comérsela así que vas a empujar la
hamburguesa hacia la derecha con una
fuerza de 4 newtons y vas a empujarla a
una distancia de 5 metros hacia la
derecha y la pregunta va a ser cuánto
trabajo realizamos al pasar esta
hamburguesa a la persona que tenemos a
nuestra derecha y como este es un
problema sencillo podríamos poner las
cantidades directamente en la fórmula de
trabajo pero no vamos a hacer esto vamos
a ver una forma alternativa de
resolverlo porque lo que vamos a
aprender de esta forma alternativa nos
va a ayudar para cuando tengamos
problemas más complejos de trabajo ahora
consideren esto en lugar de poner las
cantidades directamente en la fórmula
vamos a considerar que realizamos un
trabajo de 4 minutos durante toda esta
distancia de 5 metros si fuéramos a
graficar la fuerza en nuestra
hamburguesa como función de su posición
se vería algo así comenzamos en cero
a 5 metros a la derecha y ejercemos una
fuerza constante de 4 newtons esta es
una línea horizontal esto quiere decir
que fue una fuerza constante y lo hago
de esta manera porque geométricamente va
a ser significativo usamos la fórmula
del trabajo el trabajo es la fuerza en
la dirección del movimiento multiplicado
por el desplazamiento o podrían decir
que es el total de la fuerza
multiplicado por el desplazamiento
multiplicado por el consell o de teta y
si no les gusta este coseno dt está
solamente asegúrense de estar ocupando
la fuerza exclusivamente en la dirección
del movimiento sólo el componente de la
fuerza que tiene la misma dirección que
el movimiento en nuestro ejemplo de la
hamburguesa la fuerza ya se encontraba
en la dirección del movimiento por lo
que esto no lo necesitamos en otras
palabras el ángulo de aquí es cero y el
coseno de cero es uno y uno por
cualquier cosa va a seguir siendo esa
misma cosa así que aquí sólo nos queda
efe por d
aquí la fuerza fue de 4 newtons la
fuerza durante todo el desplazamiento
de 5 metros y nos queda que es 20 jules
el trabajo realizado en la hamburguesa
fue de 20 jules positivos y si son
astutos se dan cuenta de que a ver esos
4 newtons y estos 5 metros pues
justamente es el área de este rectángulo
ya que si se fijan esta línea horizontal
en esta gráfica de fuerza me va a formar
un rectángulo y esos 4 newtons son la
altura de este rectángulo y los 5 metros
son la base y si multiplicamos base por
altura nos va a dar el área del
rectángulo así que encontramos que
cuando la fuerza es constante el trabajo
va a ser igual al área bajo esta curva
el área limitada por la gráfica y esa es
otra forma de encontrar el trabajo
además de usar la fórmula que ya tenemos
aquí es el área que se forma justo a
partir de esta línea de la fuerza hasta
donde se encuentra nuestro eje x esto va
a ser igual al trabajo realizado
y ustedes me pueden decir vaya pues qué
novedad esto lo pudimos encontrar
directamente usando la fórmula porque me
interesa saber que el trabajo es igual
al área bajo la curva en un diagrama de
fuerza les voy a mostrar por qué y
pudimos haber usado la fórmula
directamente pero no todos los casos van
a ser así de simples qué pasaría si
nuestra fuerza no fuera constante si
tuviéramos una fuerza que estuviera
variando cual fuerza podríamos usar si
ese está cambiando bueno una forma de
manejar este ese medio es usando cálculo
pero si ustedes no saben cálculo
afortunadamente hay otra forma de
determinar el trabajo y es justamente
esta idea el área en cualquier gráfica
de fuerza contraposición va a ser igual
al trabajo y no sólo cuando la fuerza es
constante esto se cumple incluso cuando
está variando la fuerza si podemos
encontrar el área bajo esta curva es una
forma rápida y sencilla de encontrar el
trabajo realizado por esta fuerza por
ejemplo en lugar de estar empujando con
una fuerza constante de 4 minutos
durante esta distancia de 5 metros
digamos que comenzamos empujando con 4
newtons pero vamos a decrementar esta
fuerza constantemente hasta que cuando
llegamos a los 5 metros vamos a tener 0
newtons nos vamos cansando cada vez que
seguimos empujando hasta que cuando
llegamos a los 5 metros ya no podemos
empujar más y quizás se pregunten cómo
es que la hamburguesa llego a esos 5
metros si fuimos empujando cada vez con
menos fuerza bueno quizás lo que pasó
aquí es que nos tardamos más tiempo en
empujarla como vamos a encontrar el
trabajo realizado en la hamburguesa
bueno continuó con la afirmación de que
el área bajo esta curva va a ser mi
trabajo
pero quizás ustedes sean escépticos y me
digan a ver lo único que me has
demostrado es que en el ejemplo anterior
el trabajo realizado para una fuerza
constante era igual al área bajo la
curva como puedo yo saber que en este
caso cuando está variando la fuerza el
trabajo sigue haciendo el área bajo esta
curva bueno los físicos y matemáticos
son bastante astutos lo que hicieron fue
decir bueno yo lo único que sé es que
para una fuerza constante el área bajo
la curva va a hacer el trabajo así que
en lugar de considerar este caso en el
que mi fuerza está disminuyendo
continuamente digamos que voy a estar
empujando con muchas fuerzas constantes
pero con un desplazamiento muy pequeño
así que comienzo con cuatro newtons pero
empujo sólo durante diez centímetros
luego bajo mi fuerza a lo mejor tres
puntos nueve newtons y empujo otros diez
centímetros y sigo haciendo esto una y
otra vez reduciendo cada vez más la
fuerza pero manteniendo esa reducción
constante y esto es útil porque
trabajo en este caso va a ser igual al
área de cada uno de estos rectángulos
sumando los todos ya que cada uno tuvo
una fuerza constante y el trabajo
realizado es la suma de la área de todos
estos rectángulos y esta es una idea muy
astuta
si hacemos estos rectángulos
infinitesimalmente pequeños su suma nos
va a dar exactamente el área bajo esta
gráfica el área de este triángulo va a
ser exactamente igual a la suma de las
áreas de estos rectángulos
infinitesimales y además es exactamente
el mismo proceso que teníamos
anteriormente imaginen que estamos
empujando con cuatro newtons pero
durante un milímetro aunque si es
infinitesimal va a ser mucho más pequeño
que esto pero para pensar en esto
conceptualmente imaginemos que empujamos
con cuatro newtons durante un milímetro
y para el siguiente milímetro voy a
empujar con 3.99 newtons y para el
siguiente milímetro empujó con tres
puntos 98 newtons y así sucesivamente
esto es prácticamente está disminuyendo
nuestra fuerza continuamente llegando a
este proceso que describimos
anteriormente pero ahora ya sabemos que
el área en estos rectángulos va a ser
igual al trabajo realizado pero es el
mismo proceso y la misma área que
calcular el área de este triángulo y
quizás
ustedes me digan a ver un momento esos
bordes me están ocasionando errores
estas esquinas de acá se están pasando o
están afuera de mi línea y además aquí
tenemos algunos huecos que están
subestimando el área y tenemos estos
errores en todos los rectángulos de
verdad esto será igual al área y si va a
ser si hacemos que la base de cada
rectángulo sea infinitesimalmente
pequeña entonces el error incurrido
también se va a ser infinitesimalmente
pequeño el error incurrido con esos
elementos que se pasen de la curva o que
quedan huecos debajo de la curva también
se van a hacer infinitesimalmente
pequeños y si el error se hace
infinitesimalmente pequeño significa que
el área en estos rectángulos
infinitesimalmente pequeños va a ser
exactamente igual que el área de el
triángulo lo cual son buenas noticias
para nosotros ya que significa que el
área bajo cualquier gráfica de fuerza
contraposición va a ser igual al trabajo
realizado por esa fuerza
y esta gráfica no tiene que ser un
triángulo podemos usar rectángulos
infinitesimales para representar
cualquier área así que el área bajo
cualquier gráfica de fuerza
contraposición nos va a representar el
trabajo y ahora tenemos una herramienta
poderosa para determinar el trabajo en
donde la fuerza no es constante esta
fórmula de trabajo en donde el trabajo
es igual a la fuerza por d por el coseno
de teta solo nos va a servir si tenemos
una fuerza constante si la fuerza está
variando entonces no podemos usar esta
fórmula pero ahora ya dijimos esto lo
cual es genial ya que si yo puedo
encontrar el área bajo esta curva
entonces puedo encontrar el trabajo por
ejemplo en este caso si yo estoy
empujando mi hamburguesa inicialmente
con 4 newtons y reduzca esa fuerza hasta
0 durante 5 metros
cuál es el trabajo realizado bueno pues
ahora se queda va a encontrar el área
bajo esta gráfica de fuerza contra
posición y como es un triángulo yo sea
encontrar el área de un tren
esta área es un medio por base por la
altura que es igual a un medio mi base
es de 5 metros y me altura es de 4
newtons lo que me dará 10 jugos
positivos de trabajo es el trabajo
realizado durante este proceso que
comenzó con una fuerza que empezó a
disminuir hasta llegar a cero y fue
durante un desplazamiento de 5 metros y
eso es lo poderoso de esta aproximación
si resulta que nuestra gráfica de fuerza
contraposición tiene una forma en la
cual podemos encontrar el área
fácilmente podemos calcular el trabajo
sin problemas el área de un triángulo o
un rectángulo o una combinación de
triángulos y rectángulos podremos
encontrar rápidamente el trabajo
realizado sin tener que conocer nada de
cálculo y para aclarar cualquier
confusión no es necesario que ustedes
dibujen rectángulos para calcular el
área fue solamente para demostrarles que
se cumple esta relación no tenemos que
preocuparnos de esos rectángulos
infinitesimales
y los usamos para demostrarnos a
nosotros mismos que incluso en los casos
donde no tenemos una fuerza constante si
la fuerza está variando aun así el área
bajo la curva va a ser igual al trabajo
y aquí hay otra cosa con la que debemos
tener cuidado cuando decimos que el área
bajo la curva es igual al trabajo nos
referimos a la línea que en la gráfica
representa a la fuerza hasta el eje x
ustedes me pueden decir claro por
supuesto que otra cosa podría ser bueno
a veces no queda tan claro cuando
tenemos casos como éste
digamos que nuestra fuerza comenzó aquí
abajo
quizás comenzamos empujando nuestra
hamburguesa hacia la izquierda y nos
dimos cuenta que no había nadie ahí
y decimos oops me equivoqué y comenzamos
a empujarla hacia la derecha por lo que
nuestra fuerza comenzó como negativa y
después se volvió positiva y ahora si
queremos encontrar el total del trabajo
realizado durante todo este proceso como
lo hacemos es que vamos a seguir usando
esta idea del área bajo la curva algunas
personas dicen bueno pues es el área
bajo
va así que en esta sección me interesa
el área que esté aquí abajo pero esto es
una locura no tenemos una cantidad
infinita de trabajo aquí el área a la
que nos referimos es esta área de aquí
la que se forma entre la gráfica y el
eje horizontal es una área finita en la
parte de aquí arriba el área a la que me
refiero es la que se forma con esta
línea que me representa la fuerza y mi
eje horizontal de la posición como
cálculo estas áreas pues ambos son
triángulos así que no es difícil un
medio base por altura es un medio por la
base esta base es de un metro por la
altura que es de menos dos newtons es
una altura negativa por lo tanto voy a
tener un área negativa es esto correcto
si en este caso si lo es ya que
significa que realice trabajo negativo
sobre esta hamburguesa así que tengo
menos un joule durante ese primer metro
en donde estuve empujando la hamburguesa
hacia la izquierda ahora
esta otra área de aquí también es un
medio por la base por la altura en este
caso la base no es de 3 metros sino
solamente de 2 metros va del 1 de 32
metros multiplicados por la altura y en
este caso la altura es de 4 newtons y
para esta porción del recorrido
realizamos 4 jules de trabajo positivo
así que 4 jules positivos para esta
porción y menos un joule en esta otra
porción el trabajo total realizado en
todo este desplazamiento es de 4 jules
menos un joule va a ser igual a 3 jules
positivo en resumen si nuestra fuerza es
constante
podemos usar directamente esta fórmula
para encontrar el trabajo
efe por de por coseno de teta pero
también podemos encontrar el trabajo al
encontrar el área bajo la curva de la
gráfica de fuerza contra posición y esto
es útil porque funciona aún cuando
tenemos una fuerza que está variando lo
que dejaría está fórmula pues casi casi
inservible
pero si la forma de la gráfica es una en
la que podemos encontrar fácilmente el
área podremos sin problema determinar el
trabajo
calculando el área bajo esta curva en
una gráfica de fuerza contra posición